one of the questions we keep asking is whether the
future of the Republican Party is in Mitt Romney.
Is it in Lindsey Graham or is it in Marjorie
Taylor Green? Mitt Romney being at this point
anyway, an anti Trump Republican, Lindsey
Graham being a formerly anti Trump Republican
who now is on the Trump side and seems to like
golfing with Trump and being in the good graces
of what was then a current and now former
president, or Marjorie Taylor Green, who exists
as an elected official only because of Trump and
came to power by riding the full on cue and on
Trump and wing of the Republican Party. And part
of it, as I've said before, depends on what Donald
Trump's presence or lack thereof ends up being.
Meaning, what does Trump decide to do? Based on
his letter that we looked at earlier today, it
seems Donald Trump is planning to at least try
to remain involved in the Republican Party and
American politics for the time being. But there
is another factor here, which is the electorate,
the Republican electorate, because remember that
without a wacky Republican electorate,
Trump's candidacy in 2016 goes nowhere.
If Trump ran in the Democratic primary, he would
have gotten nowhere because Democratic primary
voters would never have been bamboozled
into making Donald Trump the nominee. So
one of the things that 2016 showed us was that
the electorate matters and that the electorates
are dramatically different in the Republican Party
and the Democratic Party. Ronald Brownstein wrote
a very interesting op ed for CNN where he asks
whether the extremist wing of the Republican Party
may be too big to fail. And there are
certain numbers that tell us that,
yes, there are way too many completely radicalized
extreme Republicans for them to be relegated to
political obscurity and irrelevance, maybe even
if Donald Trump goes quietly into the night and
opt out of American politics, which again, for
now, it doesn't seem like he's looking to do.
And as Brownstein points out in this article, the
American Enterprise Institute, a right wing think
tank, did a poll and found that nearly a third
of Republicans embrace the convoluted, kuhnen
conspiracy theory that Marjorie Taylor Greene
has been espousing, that Trump is defending the
country against this sort of a cabal of child sex
traffickers. A third of Republicans believe that
one sixth to one fifth of Republicans have praised
the January 6th riots and polling from Quinnipiac.
55 percent of Republicans agree that, quote,
We may have to use force to save the American
way of life. Four in 10 agree with the phrase,
if elected leaders will not protect America,
the people must do it themselves, even
if it requires taking violent actions.
Vanderbilt University did a study and found
that 51 percent of Republicans agree with the
statement that, quote, We may have to use force
to save the traditional American way of life.
Four in 10 back the idea that a time will come
when patriotic Americans have to take the law
into their own hands. And in the
American Enterprise Institute poll,
half of Republicans said that the attack on
January 6th was engineered not by Trump ists,
but by antifa. These aren't fringes when so many
people believe this stuff. These aren't five,
seven, 11 percent beliefs in the Republican
Party. So, yes, we should be afraid because
if that contingent takes over the party for
the long term, it's a dystopian nightmare.
Now, I think it bears repeating that Trump didn't
create most of this. These extremists have been
around in American politics for a long time.
They just didn't always vote. They weren't always
public about their beliefs. And they didn't have a
candidate that coalesce them and brought them out.
And that's what's so dangerous about what's
going on right now. So the best scenario is
that the party is split. The Romneys have to
fight the Lindsey Graham's and the Kuhnen people,
and they all end up so busy fighting each other
that they end up unable to stop Joe Biden and
Democrats from hopefully getting things done. Now,
Mitch McConnell knows that that's the risk part of
Mitch McConnell voting not guilty on conviction
on Saturday and then giving a speech saying
how Donald Trump is, practically speaking and
morally speaking, completely responsible for the
riots. Part of this is Mitch McConnell, desperate
to figure out a way. To not be tied up in fighting
so that he can get back to what he's an expert in,
and I say that not joking, he's really an expert
in obstructing Democrats from getting anything
done. The best case scenario is that they end up
infighting and aren't able to obstruct. The worst
case scenario is really bad, and it includes that
they are able to obstruct. And these Trumpy and
clowns, the Kuhnen types, continue getting elected
in the future. And that gets me really to the
next thing I want to talk about, which is that
this is a problem that is much bigger than
one insurrection. The insurrection is a lens.
It's a it's a it's not really a mirror, but
in a sense, it's a mirror. It's a one way
mirror that lets us look at the bigger problem of
radicalization. So I want to talk about that next.